il avait lu claire bonsoir bonsoir
comment comment vous la jugez ou
peut-être comment la comprenez vous
m'aider j'essaye de voir comment en
elles cohabitent les forces du mal et du
bien
j'essaie de la comprendre ne savait pas
de la justifier on peut pas justifier la
monstruosité dont à aucun moment mais
des ne fait l'économie elle est
véritablement à un moment donné
traversée par les forces du mal à
l'homme à la jouissance
donc il s'agit pas de l'ange elysées
mais simplement de laisser la comprendre
d'essayer de comprendre sa souffrance et
par là même de la de la rend proche de
nous de la rendre contemporaine
il ya un moment dans le bal et
diablement dans la pièce et emma dante
dans le texte où on al impression
lorsque vous décrivez ce situation de
femme c'est une sorte de fatalité des
femmes face aux hommes
c'est ce qui se dégage de la pièce
d'euripide
on a l'impression que la seule fatalité
qui accable m'aider c'est d'être une
femme et non pas elle agit pas au nom
d'une fatalité des dieux qui la
désignent comme la grande coupable
elle est au contraire a priori elle est
plutôt la victime expiatoire du groupe
elle est l'étrangère qui est qui est
rejeté et son parcours est aussi un peu
oui là une sorte de métaphore d'une
misérable condition féminine comme comme
rippy de nous la décrit avec des accents
étrangement contemporain et encore une
fois proche à l'époque où il écrit la
pièce mais par quel parcours et vous
arrivez à m'aider à travailler avec la
salle est allé à la cour d'honneur
un parcours assez simple bernard faivre
d'arcier depuis déjà un certain temps ne
proposait de de jouer dans la cour
d'honneur et il me faisait 7
cette confiance et puis un peu plus tard
il m'a fait rencontrer jacques lassalle
et voilà je crois que c'était c'était
vraiment le meilleur metteur en scène
avec qui je pouvais le faire
qui justement d'emblée m'a invité à
remplacer mais des dents peut-être dans
une galaxie d'héroïne que j'ai
interprété à l'écran
j'ai trouvé dans le supplément de
télérama sur la vigne en 2000 vous dites
les monstres m'attire pour lui expliquer
les monstres m'attire oui j'aime encore
une fois oui j'aime dégager ce qui peut
y avoir de de douloureux dans des
personnages dont c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire sont pas faites pour a
priori attirer la sympathie voilà alors
c'est toujours intéressant pour une
actrice de de dégager ce qui peut y
avoir de contradictoire d'humains
d'aller d'aller au delà des apparences
et j'ai eu la très bonne surprise en
lisant la pièce de répit laquelle moi ça
quel point c'était possible il ya
plusieurs mais dès qu'on était écrite
celle de sénèque et beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus meurtrière est beaucoup
plus monstrueuse et c'est toujours aussi
intéressante à travers des grands
personnages clastiques de de dégager ce
qui toutes les correspondances et tous
les échos qu'on peut trouver maintenant
est de dégager les personnages du du
poids de leurs mythes et 2 lors de leur
rendre leurs oeufs au fond leur banalité
mais ce qu'ils ont chacun
ce qui surprend isabelle huppert c'est
que font à travers certains au
personnage devait incarner au cinéma ou
la dent mais des comme si vous aviez une
attirance pour la solitude pour une pour
des personnages très solitaire
souvent ce sont les les plus beaux
personnages non en fait il n'ya pas que
cela qui m'attire je serai très contente
de jouer une comédie ou de jouer des
personnages plus légers mali dans c'est
vrai que cdc des personnages qui nous
utilement qui sont seuls mais le
peut-être au théâtre on est toujours
seuls 2,4 et les faits pour ça aussi
plus que peut-être encore plus où il ya
un mystère théâtrale et et à travers le
théâtre il ya un questionnement qui qui
nous est seul et en même temps qui
consiste peut-être à établir un lien
peut-être un peu moins seul à l'arrivée
j'espère en tous les cas
il ya il ya quelque chose de particulier
qui s'attache à cette cour d'honneur
tels que vous avez pu le ressentir déjà
dans les répétitions
écoutez oui il ya quelque chose de
particulier il ya quarante ans tout ce
qu'on dit autour de cette cour d'honneur
pour s'en convaincre
et en même temps il ya qu'a aussi
marcher dans cette cour d'honneur
peut-être pour se persuader du contraire
à savoir que c'est surtout un lieu assez
extraordinaire où les changes entre le
entre le public et les spectateurs ne
paraît possible
alors j'espère que j'en dirais autant
mercredi soir mais il me semble je suis
allé plusieurs fois comme comme
spectatrice et je suis frappé à chaque
fois comme les acteurs ne paraissent
proches
alors après ça il ya tous les fantômes
qui hantent cette cour d'honneur merci
aussi merci beaucoup et c'est bête
d'avoir répondu en direct avec tous
c'est que c'est un petit peu compliqué
comme ça quand on est en préparation
d'une telle représentation je serai je
sais que ceux qui vous ont déjà vu vous
on trouve effectivement extraordinaire
donc on pensera à vous pour mercredi
soir merci d'avoir été en direct
d'avignon
je remercie aussi nos amis de tristan
nolin patrick poncet me